ça sera quoi l'homme idéal pour vous
pour moi ça serait un garçon qui
physiquement d'abord ça serait un garçon
brun matt de peau je me paraît même
qu'ils soient blancs un brin coran le
plus grand que mes 80 75 ou la peau mate
le cheveu noir mais j'aime bien les
pommes la peau mate dont les yeux sont
mutés qu'un enfin du moment bien habillé
style funky pas donc le noir quelqu'un
de se soigner
boitant bas dieu bah oui un chômeur non
non et quoi d'autre ils nous respectent
comment qu'ils nous prennent pas pour la
femme de service pour qu'ils ne prennent
pas seulement pour la mère de ses
enfants
on est quand même personne et je serai à
moitié c'est sûr ce sera lui tu
partageras tout ne va pas rester dans
son fauteuil qui est quand même les
essais sur moi peut-être vous brûle un
peu non
puis qui subissent mais qu'a pris ce
qu'ils soient marins c'est surtout
qu'ils s'éclatent qui rigole qui aiment
la gaieté comme je puisse me surprendre
comme les choses inhabituelles
je m'appelle jacques lille j'ai 55 ans
je travaille comme secrétaire médicale
j'ai cinq enfants dans le dernier à 22
ans je suis marié depuis 33 ans
toujours avec le même homme oui pourquoi
est ce que vous l'avez poser à j'ai
poussé parce que je l'aimais et puis on
avait la même éthique chrétienne
et puis je l'épousé parce que
était beau et beaucoup de filles est
amoureuse de lui et moi ça me valoriser
parce que je me trouvais trouvait pas
belle je me trouvais mal habillé pauvre
petite empreinte d'un tas de trucs et
kim ait choisi samassa m'a paru
extraordinaire enfin c'est vraiment ça a
été je n'ai pas dormi la nuit oui ma
demande en mariage je n'ai pas dormi
vous avez été un couple très uni très
très très pendant jusqu'à jusqu'à enfin
de certaines époques fréquents pas
jusqu'à il ya eu c'est ce que je fais
mais 68 jeudi jusqu'à mai 68 c'est aussi
tu sais un petit peu par rapport à mai
68 ce que c'est mais en fait ça va
peut-être commencer un petit peu avant
j'ai commencé à me poser des questions
mais c'est par rapport à la fois comme
je vous ai dit mon mari il était très
très croyant très moi aussi un mais moi
je me posais des questions je trouve que
l'église était misogyne je trouvais que
petit à petit c'est venu et en mai 68 ça
a éclaté bon alors j'ai milité j'ai
distribué des tracs j'étais aux
manifestations et alors ça c'était mon
mari disait mais tu vois pas une mère de
cinq enfants de quoi tu as l'air encore
les jeunes que j'étais là dans une
lecture il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
étudiants ça tombait comme ça puis en
même temps
en même temps il s'est passé que j'ai
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu la foi petit à
petit est vraiment alors ça ça a été
pour lui quelques chose de défauts fans
mais le l'effondrement tout son monde
parce que un jour j'ai dit bon ben moi
je vais plus à la messe et lui ne suit
il a dit bon bah moi non plus rejeter
mais vas-y tu peux y aller tout seul on
n'est pas obligé de croire la même chose
mais si ici moi si on n'y va pas tous
les deux pour moi ça n'a plus de sens ni
continuer à croire voyez c'était et j'ai
eu l'impression vraiment de tout le fuit
sa vie en l'air parce que pour lui
c'était important parce que moi je
sentais qu'il y avait une crise que
c'était que c'était important qu'on en
discute qu'on met même qu'on dise même
tout ce qu'il y avait
2 qui n'allait pas si vous voulez il lui
ça le jeu c'est pas ça le fermer saab
bloqué il rêvait pas
c'est peut-être une des choses que je
reproche plus moi ça de j'y suis arrivé
à force de deux bagarres assad essayer
de le faire
le faire discuter sur tout ce qui parce
que moi je tentais que sinon bon bah je
laissais tomber puis je ficher le camp
c'était fini si on ne pouvait pas
approfondir un petit peu ce qui ce qui
n'allait pas quoi il a changé dans sa
façon de vivre enfin petit à petit si
vous voulez avant moi quand on s'est
marié il me disait le matin tu as eu
crème au café quand je disais ben oui ah
ouais mais tu me le permet alors voyez
c'était il est élevé par une mère qui le
couve est littéralement et j'ai moi
j'avais petit à petit j'ai essayer de
ressembler à sa mère enfin partys icm en
innée mais d'essayer de faire tout
voiliers de 2,2 que tout soit prêt quand
il arrive que tout essayé d'être la mère
qu'il voulait pour ses enfants enfin
tout ça
puis petit à petit je me suis révolté ça
a été l'un vers est alors maintenant ça
serait plutôt lui qui me sucre mon café
ou leurs mules
non mais hilare sont l'âge maintenant
voyez il a son linge il met la table il
fait à manger on s'est retrouvé sur ce
qui est essentiel finalement
je m'appelle nathalie en jeu 20 ans je
suis célibataire je travaille en tant
qu'hôtesse mais ma passion c'est la
danse
alors pour pouvoir me payer des cours je
fais ce travail doté leur migration
vivoux pluzz physiquement vous avez dit
oui oui j'ai un type sacrant bruns les
yeux peu importe les yeux c'est
l'expression des yeux c'est c'est un
sourire c'est un charme character
caractère il faut qu'il soit gai joyeux
faut qu'ils sachent prendre des
initiatives pour faux pas s'ennuyer
[Musique]
l'année vous avez eu des aventures avec
des garçons déjà bien sur wii une
version que le ménage 20 ans c'était
c'était le grand amour
c'était la folie c'était ne plus manger
le soir c'était un peu mangé le matin
c'était je pensais tout le temps tu t'es
gay comme je mangeais pas j'étais bien
dans ma peau
j'avais un peu maigri s'asseyent fait
beaucoup de bien dans sa peau et puis de
s'en tirer mais on se sent belle sont
désirables et si on n'a pas ça on peut
pas vivre ça dure et combien de temps ça
a duré quatre mois
qu'est-ce que vous ne mettiez pas chez
lui on pouvait pas discuter avec lui et
puisqu'elle avait une certaine manière
de voir les choses mais il parlait pas
et ça ça me rendait dingue
il parlait pas de lui n'at il parlait
pas de lui parlez pas des autres ils
parlaient pas tout court il e mail
silence et moi le silence ça me rendait
dingue qui auront pu la première fois
c'est lui
la deuxième c'est moi est ce que c'est à
cause de ce manque de communication
non non non c'est parce qu'une fois il
m'avait trompé et c'est une chose je ne
vais pas je me suis pas sorti intact
mais c'était vis-à-vis de moi vous à
l'heure de dire que les relations entre
hommes et femmes
c'est pas car pour moi ce sera jamais
cannes mais vous avez eu d'autres
garçons en vous devez bien sûr pourquoi
est-ce que ça n'a pas duré
parce que je suis quelqu'un de très
instable et j'ai besoin d'aller un peu à
droite à gauche et j'ai pas envie de
m'attacher j'ai peut-être peur aussi de
m'attacher réseau moi qui pars en
premier préférez l'amour ou le dos à la
danse mais on peut pas vivre aussi sans
amour tant que j'ai besoin des deux de
toute manière vous avez quelque chose à
reprocher aux hommes en voyez beaucoup
de choses à reprocher aux hommes c'est
que pour moi les hommes maintenant
prennent pas de responsabilité vis-à-vis
des femmes c'est à dire qu'au niveau des
relations amoureuses
ils n'ont plus est cet élan qu'ils
avaient avant et comptent plus sur la
femme à la limite c'est la femme qui
drague et l'homme se laisse faire c'est
très bien je suis je suis pour ça aussi
mais il ya des limites à ce que les
garçons vous demande si vous prenez la
pilule
justement non c'est justement sur ce
point c'est complètement aberrant c'est
que eux se décharge complètement de
cette contraception il ne l'admettent
pas et
ils s'en moquent pour eux c'est évident
qu'une fille prend la pilule
puis elle prend pas la pilule tant pis
pour elles c'est plus leurs problèmes
c'est un manque de respect envers la
femme personnellement je ne mets pas le
plaisir c'est important moi je pense que
c'est essentiel plaisir qu'est ce que
vous attendez d'un homme sur ce plan là
qui me donne ce plaisir est ce que vous
êtes attentive aux siens peut-être pas à
mon âge on peut pas être attentives à
celui de l'homme on est déjà attentif à
soi même on peut pas pour moi l'avenir
c'est déjà de vivre au jour le jour
après après on verra mais avec un homme
sans homme avec un homme si si si ça
vient
et puis sans heurts mais me 606 saviem
pas c'est pas c'est pas aussi important
m'appelle catherine j'ai 33 ans je suis
célibataire et je suis écrivain
journaliste c'était pas trop mal
ah oui c'est très important parce que je
crois que dans le travail que je trouve
mon identité et financièrement et
financièrement c'est très important j'ai
jamais jamais dépendu de de quelqu'un
alors un homme qui veut vous séduire
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait de l'argent
ou pas alors oui ah ça c'est une bonne
question parce que oui oui j'ai
c'est pâques c'est ambigu parce que par
exemple j'ai remarqué que quand je sais
qu'un homme veut me séduit à nouveau
restaurant si on partage
l'addition pour moi il dire
automatiquement un copain et alors que
si j'avance ans qui m'a vite j'ai
l'impression que que là on peut
commencer à voir une relation
je sais je suis très midinettes et des
conduites qui me font qu'ils me font
démarrer mais tout de suite dire que moi
mais dans un aéroport et on me dit
choisi la destination
je trouve ça fantastique c'est le rêve
pour moi genre d'homme qui me séduit je
sais en fait je ne sais pas que les gens
donnent qui me séduit parce que c'est
je peux même pas dire que ce soit des
critères physiques
c'est vrai j'aime beaucoup les hommes
très beau corps quand je vois dans mon
paysage pas c'est un homme très beau je
sais qu'il va se passer quelque chose
parce que quelque part alors maintenant
j'ai analysé maintenant je suis plus
vieille ça me rassure de séduire des
hommes très beau je me dis si je séduis
un homme très beau c'est que je suis
très belle et ça c'est bon alors
quelquefois se marier alors des
aventures nous sommes très beau qui dure
pas longtemps
une fois que je rassure et ça y est fois
que j'ai bon ça y est je mets ça y est
ça va bon et sinon je crois que ce qui
me plaît chez un homme c'est c'est les
gens qui reste toujours une énigme et
que j'arrive pas à circonvenir à avoir
voilà et je crois que c'est ça qui me
séduit 6 adams et quand ils existent
quand ils me résiste et quand il dure à
l'emploi voilà c'est les trois critères
ce qui est rare
et si vous résiste complètement alors là
on retourne dans un autre comportement
névrotique c'est que je dorme folamour
parce que bon là c'est je crois que ça
doit être des retours au schéma l'enfant
c'est à dire que moi j'étais chez un
enfant de divorcés j'ai été abandonné
par mon père quand j'avais 10 ans et je
sais que j'ai un schéma de séduction
abandon c'est à dire que que qu'un homme
qui me résister kim abandonne je tombe
raide dingue amoureuse de lui mais je
lui faire payer ce que m'a fait papa
alors je loge séduit je fais tout pour
qu'il tombe très très amoureux et une
fois que je les ai que je sens qu'il est
amoureux mais à la limite je vais
jusqu'à lui dire des choses que je ne
pense pas pour la voir jeudi je voudrais
me marier un jour avoir des enfants ce
qui est pas vrai parce que je ne dirais
pas mais une fois que je lai j'ai une
conduite tu laisses tomber jeu parce que
j'ai pris notre revanche c'est pas un
comportement de [ __ ] mai mais je suis
sincère est ce que voulait prévenez un
peu à l'avant ce que ça va s'arrêter
maintenant si je préviens c'est possible
pourquoi
mais non faut pas dire à quelqu'un je te
préviens plus dit un jour je veux des
enfants de toit et le lendemain au lieu
dit organisée salle horreur ces sabres
ont singé antin
qu'est ce que vous attendez d'un homme
que vous séduisez comme ça qu'ils soient
un amant exceptionnel ça c'est important
oui oui et bien si vous ça c'est une
donnée moderne c'est la génération post
pilule c'est à dire que j'ai quelqu'un
qui est vraiment un mauvais coup quand
même pas très très longtemps - qu'on
soit folle d'amour qu'on veut faire une
éducation mais ce qui est bizarre c'est
que au début avec ce genre de
davanture là ce que je recherche une
fusion j'ai à présent je redeviens un
bébé géant son jeu je régresse
complètement et je sais une fusion avec
mais c'est comme petite fille avec papa
bonjour à tous je vous retrouve les
mêmes comportements et le sexe a pas
vraiment d'importance au bout d'un
moment que ça devient important quand
c'est vraiment bon c'est vraiment un
mauvais coup vous dites on sent mieux
mais au début c'est même pas important
et dans une longue liaison de plusieurs
années ça oui là c'est important
n'aimeriez pas être un homme
j'aimerais pas être un homme aux 83
c'est évident je les plains beaucoup ça
très dur
pourquoi parce que eux ils ont été
habitués à plat de comportement qui ne
marchent plus aujourd'hui
enfin devant les femmes actuelles et
puis comme c'est trop neuf
ils savent pas comment les prendre ça
doit être terriblement déroutant pour un
homme dur j'ai beaucoup de copains j'ai
beaucoup de copains aussi et on parle
beaucoup de ces choses là ils sont
paumés ils sont complètement paumée mais
moi je peux pas leur donner une
indication je ne peux pas parce que on
en est on est au début de changement des
femmes et tout est contradictoire
en ce moment je vis en couple séparé
voilà c'est à dire qu'on vit ensemble
chacun dans son appartement
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
mis ensemble ça fait sept ans qu'on vit
ensemble et moi je suis partie en
juillet vous avez vécu dans le même
appartement pendant sept mois
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes reparti
j'ai partie parce que je ne supportais
plus le côté train-train conjugale on
faisait plus aucun effort on était
ensemble parce qu'on entend on est bien
mais alors il se passait plus rien
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose
pas tout le temps étant pendant un an et
se passe rien et je sentais un espèce de
laisser aller on ne sait plus d'efforts
parler nos cheveux ont tissé enfin
c'était c'est à dire que le rapport car
ne vous conviennent pas non je suis pas
pour tempête tout le temps mais non ce
que je ne supporte pas c'est vrai ce que
je ne supporte pas c'est le couple s'est
on n'en parle pas parce que si on en
parle et les problèmes et voilà je ne
supporte pas les entassements de
problème
puis un jour le couple éclate on se
demande pourquoi mon coin ya un problème
le prend de problème il écoute là ça va
pas moi je ne peux pas ce qui est
peut-être un peu dramatique et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on passe par des hauts
et des bas mais en même temps on a un
rapport très vivante 17 ans je suis avec
lui mais là on vit pas ensemble on s'est
pas vue pendant cinq mois - et se passe
des choses je peux le regarder en face
je vais rien planqué tout ce qu'on a
vécu c'est vrai jamais fait semblant
j'aime vraiment dit mais jamais ils ont
fait semblant de prendre mon pied jamais
fait semblant et clé et quand ça va pas
je le vois à j'écoute voilà ça va pas
évidemment il y en a marre a aidé
vraiment me dit comment est ce que vous
voyez l'avenir un homme des enfants
voilà ils prennent un gros problème du
problème des enfants
certes tout ce que je viens de dire là
quand j'ai quand il ya un enfant je peux
plus parler comme ça pourquoi
et quand vous comme fait un enfant enfin
moi c'est ma vision un des enfants c'est
le jour j'aurai un enfant ça sera
l'enfant d'abord donc mes fantasmes et
désire mais en vide absolu mais
exigences se passera après mais votre
enfant passera avant tout le monde y
compris avant le père non moi de mon
problème c'est savoir si c'est de savoir
qui passera avant moi parce que mes mais
qu'est ce que devient de peur dans cette
affaire le père israël sera qui sera le
père
et est-ce qu'il sera votre mobile ah ben
oui si je fais un enfant oui bon c'est
qu'une femme en droit de faire un enfant
avec un homme et de le quitter en
emmenant l'enfant je trouve ça très
injuste pour l'homme jeu ça monstrueux
pour vous le feriez vous n'aurez pas le
courage moi parce que je n'aurai pas le
courage je pense pas que je reste
courage heures c'est peut-être de la
lâcheté mais je me vois mal font ça ça
que je sais et c'est pour ça que j'ai
peut-être peur de faire un enfant parce
que je sais que je joue je ferai un
enfant et y aura plein de choses que je
m'interdirais c'est peut-être pour ça
que j'ai peur de faire un enfant
ce que j'ai tellement envie de vivre
[Musique]